are you gonna see a big election losses
prime minister are you preparing to lose
seats Rishi sunak head in for weekly PM
queues but this session not quite so
routine as the Prime Minister eyes his
fast big Ballot Box test a lot at stake
the choice is clear vote conservative Mr
Speaker
after that pitch in the chamber the PM
to buckinghamshire today promoting his
new strategy to tackle fraud we get I
get the government gets the scale of
this problem a VM with a measure two of
his party's problems with voters as he
weighs up Thursday's council elections
with trepidation you've always said
these are going to be a tough set of
Elections for us we're concentrating on
delivering on people's priorities to a
local level we're going to keep
delivering for people my priorities are
the people's priorities
kids storm of the labor leader today in
Kent every single member of The Shadow
cabinet has been down here has reported
back to me it's really positive working
hard to make Headway here and translate
National poll leads into concrete wins
this is going to be all about the cost
of living uh it's absolutely clear the
government's got nothing to say about
that we've got a positive case to tell
we're putting that case to people and we
hope that we'll be able to make some
progress tomorrow
pounding the Pavements to make progress
to the liberal Democrats their leader
trying to take on the Tories in the
South we go into Thursday very hopeful
we're getting a great response on the
doorstep we're finding lifelong
conservatives telling us they'll never
vote conservative again they're so
shocked and appalled by the bad
management of our country
Thursday's local elections matter not
just because they'll decide who runs
hundreds of councils across the country
but they're also the last big electoral
test before the general election and
they'll help us better assess whether
labors really on course to win power
over there
local elections but with a national
story too giving us an indication of
which way the countries sway in Beth
Rigby Sky News Westminster